Y si te dijera que el nuevo enemigo de los
Talibanes dentro de Afganistán son los salafistas?
¡Habéis oído bien! Hablamos de un enfrentamiento
religioso en toda regla. Y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando en este momento ¿Pero qué clase de lucha
religiosa pueden tener si... profesan la misma
fe? Tanto los talibanes como los salafistas creen
en el Islam Sunnita y ambos son extremistas ¿Qué
diferencias pueden tener?
¡Pues muchas!
Veréis, dentro del Islam hay 4 escuelas jurídicas
distintas. Los talibanes siguen la escuela hanafi,
que no tiene nada que ver con la salafista.
Y diréis ¿En qué se diferencian? Pues los
talibanes permiten interpretar los textos
sagrados usando la razón y la opinión. Sí,
ya sé que razón y talibanes parece una
contradicción. Pero es que los salafistas
son aún más radicales, porque dicen que los textos
sagrados no se pueden tocar ni en la última coma.
Por supuesto, durante la guerra de Afganistán,
los talibanes y los salafistas tuvieron ciertas
alianzas. Sobre todo con ese grupo terrorista
de confesión salafista que todos conocemos:
Al Qaeda. Sin embargo, con Estados Unidos
fuera, han vuelto a los enfrentamientos.
No obstante, no creáis que hablamos de
una guerra abierta. La realidad es que
los salafistas son una minoría en Afganistán.
En parte, gracias a la opresión taliban. Esto
no significa que Afganistán sea ningún
paraíso de tolerancia. Todo lo contrario.
Como vamos a ver en este vídeo, hay muchas
formas de radicalismo islámico. Y todas ellas
pueden ser violentas y peligrosas. Pero
hoy vamos a centrarnos en los SALAFISTAS.
Y diréis ¿Por qué nos interesan tanto los
salafistas? Pues porque es una de las ramas
del Islam de más rápido crecimiento. Los
salafistas han ido expandiéndose por el
mundo desde hace décadas ¿Por qué? Pues
porque cuentan con el músculo financiero
para hacerlo ¿De quién hablamos? Pues
nada más y nada menos que de un viejo
conocido aquí en VisualPolitik: Arabia Saudita.
¡Pero no creáis que hablamos sólo de mezquitas
radicales en Occidente! El salafismo se está
expandiendo también por todo el mundo musulmán.
Muchos países musulmanes moderados están
sucumbiendo a los encantos del radicalismo
salafista. Así que las preguntas que hoy nos
hacemos son: ¿Por qué debemos preocuparnos
por el salafismo? ¿Qué impacto puede tener
en nuestras vidas? ¿Por qué el salafismo es
tan atractivo en países musulmanes? Hoy vamos
a responder a estas preguntas pero antes...
[Antes quiero recordaros que, si os gusta
VisualPolitik, ahora podéis apoyar activamente
este proyecto ¿Cómo? Pues suscribiéndoos al
Patreon de VisualPolitik. Además de permitir que
este proyecto pueda seguir adelante, si os unís
a nuestro Patreon, recibiréis nuestra newsletter
“Las claves de la Semana”, donde tocamos muchos
más temas que no nos da tiempo a cubrir en forma
de vídeo. Además, a partir del nivel 3, recibiréis
nuestro merchandising exclusivo. Merchandising
que nunca estará a la venta. Tenéis todos
los enlaces en la descripción. Y ahora sí,
vamos a ver un poco de historia.]
(DR. SALAF AND MR. YIHAD)
Todos asociamos Salafismo con Arabia Saudita.
Sin embargo, el salafismo nace en la actual
Iraq en el siglo IX. La palabra “Salafismo”
viene de “Salaf” que es como se llamaba a
los estudiosos del Islam tras la muerte de
Mahoma. Y los salafistas eran estudiosos
que defendían que los textos sagrados no se pueden
interpretar. Se tienen que aplicar “a raja tabla”.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué tiene que ver el Salafismo
con Arabia Saudita? Pues todo viene del siglo
XVIII cuando un clérigo que se llamaba AL-WAHHAB
convirtió al jefe tribal más importante de la
zona - Lo único que en vez de llamarlo salafismo,
en un acto de humildad lo llamó wahabismo, porque
claramente lo último que quería era ser famoso.
El resto es historia: en los años 30 del siglo XX,
Arabia Saudita descubre que tienen zumo de
dinosaurio para dar y vender. De repente, un
montón de inmigrantes de otros países musulmanes
emigran para trabajar en los campos de petróleo
saudíes. Y entre barril de petróleo y oraciones
diarias... se terminan convirtiendo al salafismo.
¡Pero no sólo eso! ¿Qué hacen todos los saudíes
con todo ese dinero que ganan con el petróleo?
Pues aquí es donde llega la gran brecha saudí
de la que ya os hemos hablado varias veces en
VisualPolitik. La Casa Real Saudí usa el dinero
para vivir a todo tren, comprarse mansiones y
coches de lujo. Sí, vale, mantienen ciertas
convenciones religiosas... pero se olvidan de
toda la parte del salafismo que dice que hay que
ser “austero” y “modesto”. Pero luego tenemos a
los Salafistas “true”. Los auténticos. Esos que,
por muy ricos que sean, nunca se pondrán un traje
de Armani porque... va contra los textos
sagrados. Estos salafistas usan su dinero
para expandir su palabra por todo el mundo.
Y, claro, alguno se preguntará, ¿qué hay de
malo en que se expanda una religión, si
todas lo hacen? Pues sí, tenéis razón.
El problema es que dentro del salafismo hay
corrientes que predican la violencia. Sí,
amigos de VisualPolitik, hablamos del Yihadismo.
Sin embargo, esperad un momento porque la Yihad es
un término bastante desconocido en Occidente. En
realidad hay dos niveles de Yihad. La YIHAD menor
consiste en la lucha contra el infiel. En este
caso, cualquiera que no practique el salafismo.
Y en la mayor parte de los casos, por “lucha”
entendemos... lucha violente. Pero luego existe la
YIHAD MAYOR. La Yihad Mayor consiste en la lucha
interna contra el mayor infiel que puede haber,
que es uno mismo. La lucha interna por controlar
nuestros propios deseos y ser fieles al Corán.
Dicho de otra forma: muchas veces podemos
escuchar a un clérigo musulman hablar de
Yihad y eso no significa necesariamente
que esté hablando de matar infieles.
Echa esta aclaración, hay algo que muchos os
estaréis preguntando ahora ¿Cómo es posible
que una religión tan radical se expanda tan
rápidamente? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(LA EXPANSIÓN DEL SALAFISMO… VERSIÓN MAL)
No es ninguna sorpresa que la religión
se utilice como un arma política, se lleva
haciendo durante toda la historia. Así que,
cuando toda África del Norte se independizó
de sus colonizadores Europeos, los salafistas
pensaron que tenían una oportunidad de
crecimiento. Y diréis ¿Les salió bien?
Pues... la respuesta es NO. Mal. Salió fatal.
Cuando Argelia estaba en guerra con Francia,
los salafistas tuvieron cierto momento de gloria.
Pero, tan pronto como Argelia se independizó,
los partidos salafistas quedaron marginados.
Durante la guerra entre India y Pakistán,
tanto Arabia Saudita como Qatar financiaron
a grupos terroristas salafistas. Pero a
duras penas lograron poder político real.
Y en Afganistán fue un auténtico fracaso. Primero,
los comunistas frenaron cualquier movimiento
religioso. Después, los talibanes frenaron a
los salafistas. Durante la última guerra de
Afganistán, los salafistas habían logrado
cierta presencia. En este caso, su principal
valedor era el Estado Islámico en la provincia
de Khorasan. Pero en cuanto los talibanes se
han hecho con todo el poder, los salafistas
han sido las primeras víctimas. Atentos.
(“Los Talibán se enfrentan al ISKP, su rival
más serio en Afganistán” Aljazeera, 27/9/2021. )
Y la misma historia tenemos con las Primaveras
Árabes. Ni en Túnez ni en Egipto han
logrado expandirse. Sí, por supuesto,
en todos estos países hay algún partido
político salafista pero: en Tunez no ganan
las elecciones y en Egipto no hay elecciones
que ganar. Sin embargo, hay una zona donde
el salafismo sí está ganando terreno ¿De qué
países hablamos? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
CÓMO EXTENDER UNA RELIGIÓN
Vale: nos ha quedado claro que el
régimen saudita quiere expandir el salafismo.
La pregunta es ¿Por qué no se frena a la Casa
Real Saudí? A fin de cuentas, Estados Unidos
tiene herramientas más que suficientes para
presionarles. Pero aquí viene el gran plot twist
de esta historia ¿De verdad es el régimen saudí
quien financia las mezquitas salafistas?
Pues... sí y a la vez no. Arabia Saudí dona
dinero a ONGs islámicas como, por ejemplo, la Liga
del Mundo Islámico. Sobre el papel, esto es ayuda
humanitaria sin más. Pero muchos de los encargados
de estas ONGs desvían dinero a la causa yihadista.
Sin embargo, buena parte de
la financiación del salafismo
internacional viene... ¡De la sociedad civil!
¡Habéis oído bien! Buena parte de la financiación
de las mezquitas salafistas fuera de Arabia
Saudita viene del sector privado. Es decir:
de esos salafistas “true” que no tienen
nada que ver con la Casa Real Saudí.
Hablamos de banqueros, empresarios inmobiliarios
y funcionarios con sueldos altísimos.
En lugar de usar su dinero para comprarse
mansiones en Marbella, lo usan para construir
mezquitas en Chechenia. Y diréis ¡Seguro que
están compinchados con el régimen saudí! Pues
lo cierto es que no. Como decíamos al principio,
los salafistas “true” odian a la Casa Real Saudí.
Consideran que se han vendido a las comodidades de
los infieles. Y os voy a dar una muestra de ello:
a nivel político, Arabia Saudita y Qatar se llevan
a matar. Esto es de primero de VisualPolitik. Sin
embargo, los salafistas “true” no entienden
de fronteras. Tanto qataríes como saudíes van
de la mano en lo que a construir mezquitas se
refiere. La religión está muy por encima de los
intereses de las distintas casas reales.
Ahora, eso sí, la Casa Real Saudí no ha
hecho prácticamente nada por evitar estos
movimientos. Pero eso es otra historia.
A estas alturas ya estaréis ansiosos de
saber dónde ha conseguido triunfar el
Salafismo. Pues preparad las maletas
porque nos vamos a... CHECHENIA.
CHECHENIA es una región de Rusia famosa por
sus campos de concentración de homosexuales.
Durante siglos, los chechenos profesaban el
Islam Sufí. Y diréis ¿Cómo ha podido entrar
el salafismo por estas zonas? Tres simples
razones: guerra, pobreza y exclusión social.
Y os estaréis preguntando, ¿qué guerra
ha tenido Chechenia? Pues una contra la
propia madre Rusia. Chechenia declaró
unilateralmente la independencia. Y en
Moscú les mandaron el ejército. Esta
fue la primera guerra ruso-chechena,
que acabó con más de 40.000 vidas en un
territorio de un millón de habitantes.
Fue un duro golpe, y después de la represión,
Rusia estableció aisló económicamente a
Chechenia ¡Craso error! Sin dinero de Rusia, a
Chechenia no les quedó más remedio que aceptar
dinero de Arabia Saudita, Qatar y Kuwait. Así
llegaron las primeras mezquitas salafistas.
Pensadlo bien: no sólo hablamos de una mezquita
donde vas a rezar sin más. Hablamos de escuelas
donde educan a los niños gratis o por
precios irrisorios. Entre lección de
matemáticas y lección de geografía, te
meten un poco de salafismo. Es decir,
el salafismo es más que una religión:
también ofrece cierta cobertura social.
Esto es especialmente atractivo en
lugares devastados por la guerra.
Y todo esto explica que, años más tarde,
cuando estalló la Segunda guerra Ruso-Chechena,
los salafistas terminaron por establecer
el Emirato del Cáucaso. Este Emirato acabó
por disolverse después de que el dinero
del yihadismo internacional fuera todo
para el Estado Islámico. Incluso muchos
Chechenos terminaron marchándose a Siria.
Sin embargo, ahora el salafismo está en horas
bajas ¿Por qué? Pues gracias a nuestro buen amigo
Putin y su aún mejor amigo RAMZAN KADYROV del
que hemos hablado alguna vez en VisualPolitik.
Kadyrov es el señor de la guerra que gobierna
en Chechenia con el apoyo de Putin. Básicamente,
Putin le dijo en su día a Kadyrov: “tu
haz las barrabasadas que quieras dentro
de tu territorio... pero no quiero ver ni
un sólo terrorista por el resto de Rusia”.
Y Kadyrov se lo ha tomado en serio. De
hecho, tiene un mensaje para todos los
Chechenos que se han ido al Estado Islámico.
“Si estos demonios aparecen por Rusia,
me encargaré personalmente de liderar
la operación para aniquilarlos”
Os voy a dar un consejo: si Kadyrov dice que
se encargará personalmente de aniquilarte,
hazle caso. La historia de este hombre
es para echarse a temblar. Por supuesto
que Chechenia sigue siendo un
lugar extremadamente pobre y
algunas zonas mantienen sus mezquitas.
Pero no está claro por cuánto tiempo.
Sin embargo, Chechenia no es el único territorio
donde el salafismo se ha expandido. ¿Dónde
más diríais que ha tenido éxito? Como muchos
habréis adivinado, en Asia Central: es decir,
en los ISTANES. Más concretamente, TAYIKISTÁN
y KIRGUISTÁN. En estos dos países, casi el 30%
de la población es partidaria del salafismo:
esto es más de 4 millones y medio de personas.
Y diréis ¿Son todos violentos? Pues no.
El Movimiento Islámico de Uzbekistán si
practica la Yihad Menor. Pero principalmente, el
salafismo en esta zona tiene un nombre. Un nombre,
por cierto, impr onunciable: HIZB UT-TAHRIR.
Hablamos de un partido político que nació
en los años 90 ¿Y por qué tienen tantos
partidarios? Principalmente por una razón:
su discurso contra la corrupción. Tal cual como lo
oís. Los salafistas parecen ser lo suficientemente
outsiders como para tomarse en serio su
retórica anti corrupción. A partir de eso,
el resto del discurso religioso entra mucho mejor.
Pero ahora la pregunta que todos os estaréis
haciendo (a no ser que seas el propio
Raznam Kadyrov) es... ¿Es necesario
combatir la expansión del salafismo?
¿Hasta qué punto es un problema real?
¿COMBATIR TERROR O COMBATIR CREENCIAS?
En efecto, queridos amigos, el mundo se ha unido
para luchar contra el salafismo yihadista. Es
decir: contra los terroristas. Para que os hagáis
una idea de la magnitud del problema solo hay que
ver los datos: entre 2002 y 2014, los principales
grupos salafistas yihadistas, es decir, el Estado
Islámico, su filial en Nigeria, Boko Haram, y , de
Al-Qaeda, acabaron con algo más de 54.000 vidas.
Casi todas estas víctimas no son de países
occidentales sino del propio mundo musulmán.
Y diréis ¿Cómo es esto posible? Pues porque, como
ya hemos dicho antes, para un salafista yihadista,
un infiel es todo el que no sea salafista.
Eso incluye a todos los demás musulmanes.
Y lo mismo ocurre en Occidente. No hace falta
que recuerde la larga lista de atentados que
hemos sufrido en toda Europa. Y es
que sí, en toda Europa contamos con
un montón de mezquitas radicales. Atentos.
(“La gran mezquita de Bruselas y su vínculo
con el salafismo- La mezquita más grande de
Bruselas está financiada por Arabia Saudí,
un régimen salafista. Los líderes se han disociado
del terrorismo – pero no están contando todo.”)
Y esto es lo que ocurre en Bélgica ¿Sabéis
lo que han hecho los franceses? Sus fuerzas
de seguridad se han infiltrado en los oficios de
las mezquitas y han descubierto cuantos clérigos
emplean discursos radicales. De hecho, entre 2012
y 2015 expulsaron a 52 clérigos del país por esto.
Vale, el terrorismo yihadista se combate, y
la radicalización también. Pero ¿Y qué pasa
con el salafismo como doctrina religiosa?
Pues en estos momentos podemos decir que el
mundo musulmán vive su propia batalla cultural.
¡Habéis oído bien! El salafismo no es la única
doctrina islámica que se intenta expandir. Hay
muchos grupos en todo el mundo que se dedican
a luchar contra el salafismo desmintiendo su
discurso y sus acciones. Uno de ellos esta en
Indonesia y se llaman NAHDATUL ULAMA. Se calcula
que tienen entre 40 y 90 millones de adeptos sólo
en Indonesia. Y ¡Ojo! Porque Indonesia es el
país con mayor población musulmana en todo el
mundo. Ahora bien, eso no significa que todas
estas organizaciones no sean radicales. Algunos
de ellos incluso plantean problemas para
los gobiernos de los países donde actúan.
Mientras, lo única opción que parece viable a
día de hoy es combatir el terrorismo. Es decir,
dejar la religión a un lado y centrarse en
las células terroristas. Y, por el momento,
la acción coordinada entre países están
funcionando relativamente bien. Desde el
año 2014, los atentados terroristas
se han reducido en un 60% en todo el
mundo. Y esto son buenas noticias para todos.
Pero ahora turno para vosotros ¿Creéis que esto
es suficiente? ¿Deberíamos presionar
más a Arabia Saudita para que evite
la financiación de grupos yihadistas? Podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en
VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribíos a este canal y
dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones. Y, por supuesto,
recordad que podéis colaborar activamente con
este proyecto pasando a formar parte de nuestra
comunidad de Patreon. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.